quand on voit
un vent de changement soulève les
prairies
on est à 100 people
[Applaudissements]
dans un champ près de red deer
c'est le branle bas pour récolter les
dernières tiges de canola avant la neige
les protéines à base de plantes sont en
train de remplacer l'or noir dans
l'ouest
et pour cause le canada et par neil plus
grand exportateur de légumineuses et de
serial au monde
et en ce moment la demande mondiale est
à un niveau jamais vu
la vague verte est en train de déferler
dans les prairies chip au moins trois
outils pendant des années l'alberta
exporter ces légumineuses à l'étranger
sans y réfléchir à deux fois
puis certaines voix se sont dits qu'il
fallait valoriser la matière première
ici à 9,8 parler qu'ils pin's légumes
qui est un trader
à calgary lester casse côtoient de plus
en plus les restaurants qui mise d'abord
sur les végétaux comme moussa doit que
c'était joli van rouwendaal et
journaliste culinaire à sibiti et au
globe and mail et/ou trice de plusieurs
livres
aujourd'hui les albertains croit au
pouvoir des petits pois comme moteur
économique pour l'avenir et c'est le
pari du gouvernement
le gouvernement a créé cinq pôles
d'innovation et de développement pour
l'aider à se sortir de la crise du
pétrole
un de ceux-ci le pôle des protéines à
base de plantes à edmonton la nocturne
alberta institute of technology à créer
un centre d'innovation culinaire pour
répondre à cette bail dans cette cuisine
laboratoire
le chef ménard de tente de créer des
aliments à partir des céréales et des
légumineuses des prix de sacrifices très
minutos crème glacée fromage beurre de
bg croustilles de champignons tchimou
match
une seule condition valoriser la matière
première locale des prairies
[Musique]
made in britain division 2 les
britanniques maîtrise funds est une des
multiples nationale qui a fait le pari
de s'installer ici un investissement de
30 millions de dollars pour
compétitionner avec les billons mythe de
ce monde
[Musique]
la protéine qu'ils retirent des pois
jaunes devient l'ingrédient tant
convoité celui qu'ils peuvent utiliser
dans l'élaboration de leurs aliments
[Musique]
nadolo 10 34
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]